you are a first generation yeah right
your parents were born in Korea yeah
yeah so I've always thought
that it is a scary proposition when a uh
anyone tells their parents you know what
I kind of like to get into improv
but there's something that uh in in
first gen when your first generation
I've always felt that the intensity knob
must be turned up yes uh and and this is
for any culture it's we just got here we
are trying to we've got to get serious
here yeah and it's very important for
you uh to to get up this ladder as
quickly as possible and then you're
telling them you know I really uh improv
and and making some goofy stuff on the
internet yeah that sounds fun to me uh
how did that go well my you know my yeah
I mean the the Immigrant kind of Journey
is is you know it I mean that's a huge
sacrifice you you leave all all your
friends your family you come to this new
place you don't speak the language you
you know you just do it so your children
could have a just a better opportunities
and um
so I I do remember you know when I
started getting interested in in doing
acting and comedy and and kind of
telling them a little bit kind of
mentioning oh you know this might be a
career path and they shut me down right
away they were like no it's not gonna
work you can't do it and I was like yeah
yeah no it's I'm not yeah it's not it's
not I'm just you know I'm just kind of
throwing it I think I'm serious yeah
yeah exactly I'm still on the
astrophysicist track yeah and then and
then uh and then I just from there on
out I just didn't tell them you know I
just kind of did it you know yeah kind
of behind their backs I still haven't
told them
that's getting harder and harder for you
yes television movies uh you know
there's they don't watch much
quickly just put on some kind of like a
medical coach
yeah that was a tough surgery
why were you operating on the brain I
thought you operated on eyes did I say
did I say brain oh no they're all
connected you know I had to go through
the eyes that's right that's right yeah
I um it's funny because my my uh parents
were we've been here many generations
but uh uh I think I was part of a very
large family right and I do get the
sense that uh and my parents were
upwardly mobile and that would had the
mission that they had that's the message
they had received from their parents who
received it from their parents
um and uh I but I think I benefited a
lot from being one of many yes because I
honestly think
I mean I see helicopter parents today
that hover over their kids and know
everything that they're doing and I love
my parents and they were really good
parents but I it was a different time
there were a lot of us I honestly don't
they think they knew what I was doing
most of the time and I think they just
were you know I graduated college and
said yeah I'm out and out in L.A now all
right which one are you third from the
top fourth from the bottom all right
yeah I mean for me getting my own rent
good enough I mean I was born and raised
in L.A so they're like here you know
they're like so and you know I they they
it was kind of hard to hide from them
like truthfully and and uh but you know
over time it's like they you know I just
they'd see me on TV it seem on a
commercial and they'd be like well that
what was that I was like it's just a
hobby you know and uh uh and the the
crazy thing was they were you know when
I told them like hey I got this
opportunity to play Kim Jong-un in a
movie uh and I was like really like do
you guys think this is okay and they
were like super excited
obviously yeah I would say yeah I'm
guessing they're from South Korea
yeah okay good yeah because you know it
gets more complicated yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no not